Oh
what is it that I enjoy most about
architecture of courses its ability to
inference certain things and certain way
of life maybe how a city gets going
people the city and I would say even the
economy of the city depends very much on
how buildings and architecture perform
but I'm very Wow
first condominium in Singapore okay so
it was another exploration for me and
for my group of young architects we want
people to leave before well live in a
community that have communal facilities
so that they are they are more
integrated and on top of that we say
look you have security of communal
living with compound common compound for
children you have lots of healthy living
potentials and that's why Penang very
was Glen totally detached units semi
detached units and Terry's housing units
has we got the step block the tower
block and then the select block the
other thing of course is car parking we
plan our
multi-storey car parks in those days
multi-story copper was new also because
well inland appropriately the part on
the garden HDV is all in the open air so
another feature was this trying to soft
cast circulation before interfering with
the safety of the pedestrian of the
playgrounds in the middle of our project
so I thought it's too relevant today so
in that sense I'm very proud
Paul Bane has got many interesting
features now being in such a beautiful
location on the top of a hill and
another pair anomic view of the harbour
the whole of seacoast in the South
really wanted to maximize these views
and hence we put all our bedrooms facing
that the living room or facing the sea
and the kitchens are facing the corridor
the corridor are also community corridor
we hope that this corridor will
encourage more interaction among
residents and we have to cater to
different family sizes
hence the split-level principle came out
to accommodate different family sizes
and so on the next feature is the fire
escape that is the prima donna I can't
help being emotional about this because
recalling those days the fire department
didn't approve our building look you're
so tall
how people would escape there were rooms
on the second level third level fourth
level and in an emergency they have to
quickly escape to an alternative route
now how do we create those alternative
routes and that's where the rear
elevation came about we thought through
and create those hanging staircases
which became such an important feature
of this building and make it so
beautiful something that we feel that
pure ideas are as can prevail don't have
to decorate it up only the powder it up
I am I was every billion support
interested in housing architecture
because I believe housing architecture
is the backbone of a city and this is
the thing that people come to contact
with that they will be directly
interacting with now this is a kind of
spirit I think we must not forget is the
kind of spirit that were not sure they
were promote they will continue to make
architecture of valuing in cities
you